[Music]
[Music]
that's Sean Connery of course as James
Bond fending off the bad guys with his
iconic Aston Martin db5 in the 1964 film
Goldfinger four cars were made for those
early Bond movies one of them will be up
for auction next week and to fulfill a
lifelong fantasy I got to take it for a
spin those gadgets actually work James
Bond was introduced to his new
automobile in Goldfinger the secret
agents dream car with all of its
cinematic spy gear quickly became as big
a movie star as Bond himself
this isn't just an important film car
it's an important automobile it's hugely
important automobile you know this is
the most famous car in the world in my
opinion so iconic
Bernie Ruprecht is senior car specialist
with RM Sotheby's who will be auctioning
off the automobile next week in Monterey
California
but first Ruprecht showed off the Aston
Martin's assets at Miller motorcars in
Greenwich Connecticut starting with the
famous front-end machine guns they come
right behind these signal lights they
pop straight out the machine guns aren't
loaded though are they not loaded with
projectiles but they do fire an oxygen
acetylene mixture so it's quite a bang
off the back we have a bulletproof
shield bulletproof shield rises up and
protects you from any assailant shooting
at you we then have caltrop nail
dispensers out of the rear taillight
here so this flips up that flips right
up and will shoot nails out the back if
you want it to and on the other side
other side has oil slick which we won't
fire today and then our last one is a
smoke screen down below the bumper
[Music]
that's enough
[Music]
it works inside the radarscreen bond
used to track Goldfinger and a personal
favorite the infamous red button
whatever you do don't touch it now why
not because you'll release this section
of the roof
an engagement far the passenger ejector
seat does the ejector seat actually work
well we've got the removable panel above
me unfortunately there's no rocket motor
underneath me today so you can't get me
I get rid of you it's not that easy
unfortunately why did they choose an
Aston Martin because it's not what Bond
drives in the books no in the books it's
a Bentley but in 1964 the Aston Martin
with all its gadgets helped modernize
Bond for the movies it's a car it's also
a fantasy exactly I mean can you imagine
taking this you know to the golf course
or to the grocery store a couple times a
year on a sweltering summer day we took
a ride in the car that has everything
except a/c they spent a million dollars
rebuilding this just about a million
dollars in invoices but they but they
didn't bother with the air-conditioning
so did not bother the air-conditioning
as I'm sure you can tell the guns though
did not disappoint
the triggers right over there Anthony
with the favorite feature this is the
gun button there it is that'll teach it
for cutting in front of me
what's a car like this worth estimate
pre-sale for the auction is between four
and six million dollars
who buys a car like this you know I
think the collector profile is anybody
from a car collector to a James Bond
enthusiast to know it really could be
anybody
and anybody with $6,000,000 anyone with
six million dollars I'm happy to take a
bake letter from anybody and come sail
night
[Music]
von Kahr did not actually appear in the
films it was one of two built after the
success of Goldfinger to remain
promotional appearances for the next
Bond film which was Thunderball a
European collector bought it in 2006 for
2 million bucks but another - another
million known - I don't as I said
they're thinking maybe that it'll get
he'll double his money I'm gonna pray
that you get that car listen I got a
ride that's all I ever wanted you ride
in the about half an hour we were
messing around pulling the money and
pulling the research the smile says it
all come on that says it all right when
I was like 8 years old I had the toy
version I never dreamed that actually
sit in it how about a GoFundMe page I'll
put you in charge exactly